thank you about mail-in voting you've
been you've been speaking out against a
lot against our mail-in voting yeah you
can be speaking a lot about that what
why should somebody who is afraid of
getting coronavirus going to public
places standing in a line etc why should
they no why should they not be allowed
to to mail in well that's going to be in
a long time from now number one you know
it's quite a ways away number one but
when you do all mail-in voting ballots
you're asking for fraud people steal
them out of mail boxes people print them
and then they sign them and they give
them in that the people don't even know
where they're double counted people take
them away they force people to vote they
harvest you know what harvesting is they
take many many ballots and they put them
all together and then they just dump
them and nobody has any idea whether
they're crooked or not look you do
mail-in voting now it's another thing to
do absentee voting or if somebody has a
medical condition where they go through
a process and they get an absentee
ballot that's okay that's different but
in California the governor sent I hear
Ora sending millions of ballots all over
the state millions to anybody to anybody
people that aren't citizens illegals
anybody that walks in California is
going to get a ballot we're not going to
destroy this country by allowing things
like that to happen we're not destroying
our country this has more to do with
fairness and honesty and really our
country itself because when that starts
happening you don't have a fair if you
have a rigged system you have a rigged
system and that's what would happen
so mail-in ballots and the governor of
California did better than any that I
could ever do in terms of explaining
when he sent out or will send out and I
don't know I think it's maybe partially
already done millions and millions of
ballots to anybody in California that's
walking or breathing many of those
people don't have the right to vote well
they'll be voting and you know what
we're not going to let it happen because
you're subvert our process and you're
making our country a joke
and the Democrats are doing it because
in theory it's good for them although
last week we won two big races we won in
Wisconsin and one in California
California 25 we won a tremendous race
in California that was that was
interested because at the end of the
race they brought in the Democrats
Democrat governor same governor he
brought in voting booths not mail-in
voting booths because they were losing
they saw that through the ballots but no
you can't do that you can't do the
mail-in ballots because you can have
tremendous fraud and remember what I
said
they'll be grabbing up from mail boxes
they'll even be printing them they'll
use the same paper the same machines and
they'll be printing ballots illegally
and they'll be sending them in by the
hundreds of thousands and nobody's going
to know the difference we can't do that
you want to vote you really have to
absentee is okay you're sick your way as
an example I have to do an absentee
because I'm voting in Florida and I
happened to be president and I live in
that very beautiful house over there
that's painted white so that's okay and
it's okay for people that are sick and
they can't get up something you know
something but voting is a great honor
it's a great honor and people love to go
out and vote and I want to keep it that
way and if we don't keep it that way
we'll have nothing but a rigged system
of this country we can't do that thank
you very much everybody thank you